Why we Kiss Under Mistletoe?
The name for mistletoe derives the fact that
mistletoe tends to spring from bird droppings
that have fallen on trees, with the seeds
having passed through the digestive tract
of the birds.
Thus, the plant was given the name “misteltan”
in Old English from “mistel”, meaning
“dung”, and “tan”, the plural of “ta”,
meaning “twig”.
Hence, “mistletoe” is another way to essentially
say “dung twig”.
Not only is mistletoe a dung twig, but most
varieties of this plant are partial parasites,
being unable to sustain themselves on their
own photosynthesis, so they leach what they
need from the particular tree they are growing
on.
Some varieties of mistletoe, such as the North
America Arceuthobium pussilum, are full parasites
in that they get all their resources from
the tree they are growing on and have no leaves.
So where did the tradition of kissing under
a parasitic poop twig come from?
The mistletoe has been considered a prized
plant throughout history going all the way
back to the Ancient Greeks, Celts, the Babylonians,
and Scandinavians.
For instance, the Ancient Greeks considered
the plant an aphrodisiac; believed it aided
in fertility; and could be used to achieve
eternal life.
According to Ancient Babylonian legend, they
had the closest thing to our current tradition
of kissing under the mistletoe.
At that time, single women looking for a mate
supposedly would stand outside of the temple
of the goddess of love.
Mistletoe was hung over the entrance to the
temple and when a potential suitor would approach
one of the ladies, they were supposed to bond
with him.
They did not kiss, however, as kissing wasn’t
a way to show affection at that time in the
Babylonian empire.
As for a more direct root of our kissing tradition,
Norseman had many traditions and legends concerning
the mistletoe.
One tradition was that mistletoe was a plant
of peace and so that when enemies met under
the mistletoe they were obliged to stop fighting
for at least a day.
Eventually, this spawned a tradition to hang
mistletoe over the doorway of one’s home
for peace and good luck.
Mistletoe became associated with Christmas
from this tradition of hanging mistletoe in
one’s home to bring good luck and peace
to those within the house.
The mistletoe would be hung around the New
Year and the previous year’s mistletoe would
be taken down, with its powers apparently
tapped.
The new plant would then provide this luck
throughout the year.
By the 18th century in Britain, this evolved
into the kissing tradition we have today.
At this time, it became popular to create
a ball of mistletoe that would be hung as
a Christmas decoration.
If a couple was found standing under the mistletoe,
they were then obliged to kiss if the mistletoe
ball still had berries.
For each kiss, one berry would be taken from
the ball.
Once all the berries were gone, all the “luck”
in love and marriage was considered to be
drained out of the mistletoe and it was now
considered bad luck to kiss beneath it, instead
of good luck as before.